what are some of the most important
things you should know about when you
start your flight training in this video
from free pilot training I'm going to
explain some of the basic things you
should know about when it comes to
operating your
[Music]
airplane what's up guys I'm Josh and
you're watching free pilot training
today we're going to be talking about
operating an aircraft and there's quite
a bit to know about operating an
aircraft but before we can just jump in
an aircraft and go fly we have to make
sure that those aircraft are airworthy
and one of the ways we can do that is to
perform a good pre-flight inspection a
pre-flight inspection is exactly what
the name implies it's important for
Pilots to do a good inspection of the
entire aircraft before we go fly it's
super hard to climb out on top of the
wing and look over something after your
airborne
yeah you don't ever want to do that in
fact you'll often hear these referred to
as walk around inspections because you
should walk around the entire aircraft
and look over everything really really
well especially on the First Flight of
the day and to keep you from forgetting
something on the inspection it's very
important to use the checklist that's
produced by the manufacturer most
aircraft have a detailed checklist in
the pilots operating handbook or the
aircraft flight manual but once you know
how to properly perform this inspection
there's nothing wrong with going to a
checklist like this which is way handier
to carry around in your flight bag
anyway these checklists are great
because they can help you follow a
logical flow when you look over
everything and that will help you ensure
that you look over everything and you
don't miss anything let's take a closer
look at the pre-flight inspection in the
PO for my sest
172h notice that cesna tells you the
most efficient way to perform this
inspection and I'm not going to read
this entire checklist step by by step
but I do want to mention that the
checklist does not always include
everything you should look at before
flight now there is a note up here that
says that you should check all the
lights if you're performing in Night
Flight but what if the beacon isn't
working in its daytime can I still go
fly according to far 91205 no you cannot
this is why it's very important for you
to know your required equipment in
addition to being able to determine if
the aircraft is airworthy that's why
it's really not enough to do a quick
walk around before you go fly you need
to check everything and make sure you're
going to be legal and safe my
recommendation is to focus on the things
you see in the checklist but look at
everything if something's broken or not
working you need to ask yourself two
questions is this thing required and if
not what do I need to do since it's
broken I know you know what to do we've
talked about that in a past video I'm
going to make a separate video that
explains how I like to perform a
pre-flight inspection on assess 172 so
be sure to keep an eye out for that but
I do want to talk about a couple more
things things you should know about on
the pre-flight inspection contaminated
fuel is a huge problem for airplanes and
there have been many pilots who have
lost their engine due to contaminants in
the fuel because of that it's important
that we check the quantity and the
quality of the fuel in our airplane
during the pre-flight inspection and the
way we do that is by taking samples from
the fuel tank sumps and the fuel
strainer valve these are the lowest
Parts in the fuel system that hold fuel
and we need to check all of these not
just one that's important because fuel
is lighter than water so it sinks to the
bottom and that's mostly what we're
checking for when we're taking these
samples yeah on occasion you might get a
little bit of sediment as well but water
is typically the biggest problem this is
because fuel tanks can contain air in
addition to fuel as you may remember
from our lesson on weather the air in
our atmosphere contains water vapor and
if that air in your fuel tanks cools off
enough to reach its due point it can
condense and form water droplets if
enough water droplets form it can can
cause a decent accumulation of water in
the fuel tanks that's why we use a fuel
tester we're checking to see if there's
any water in there and getting rid of it
if there is in addition to that the same
thing can happen in the fuel tank of the
fuel truck at the FBO where you're
getting fuel these fuel trucks usually
have filters and water separators to
reduce the water in the fuel but they
don't always catch everything that's why
it's important to check the fuel before
flight and after you've filled your
tanks with fuel even if you've been
flying the airplane and you're just
topping it off on fuel really quick if
you do find water in the fuel don't
freak out it's fine just continue to
drain all the sumps and the strainer
valve until you get all of it some
manufacturers May recommend shaking the
wings a little bit if you do find water
in the tanks that will ensure that you
get all of it out so be sure to check
the PO to see if that applies to your
aircraft now one thing you can do to
reduce the amount of water in the tanks
is to top off the fuel and fill them
completely after every flight by filling
the tanks completely that reduces the
amount of air in the tanks if there's
less air in the tanks that's less air
that can condense and form moisture
remember water don't burn too good it
ain't got no gas in it let's move on and
discuss a few things you should know
about when it comes to the engine
ignition and electrical system on your
training aircraft because you need to
have a pretty decent understanding of
these systems if you want to make good
decisions during an emergency before you
even start up the engine another
important thing to check during the
pre-flight is the engine oil not only
does it Lu at the moving Parts in the
engine but it also helps keep the engine
cool because it removes that friction
between all those moving metal Parts
because of that it's important to check
the oil before flight and continue to
monitor the oil throughout the rest of
the flight and the way we monitor the
oil in Flight is by using an oil
pressure gauge and an oil temperature
gauge if the engine is air cooled and
these two gauges are so important that
the FAA has made them required equipment
items according to far
91205 as soon as you crank your engine
and get get started up the first thing
you want to do is pull your power back
to about 1,000 RPM on most training
aircraft this will allow the oil in your
engine to warm up properly and spread
the oil more evenly throughout the
system once you've done that you should
look at all the gauges but you should
focus on the oil pressure and
temperature the nice thing is that you
don't have to remember any numbers as
long as both of them are in the green
you're good to go the engine temperature
is going to start out low but as the old
girl warms up it should get pretty warm
but it should stay in the green but what
should I do if my engine starts getting
too hot on the ground you can just shut
the engine down but you don't always
want to do that in Flight especially in
a single engine aircraft if the engine's
getting too hot sometimes the only
indication Is high oil temperature on
this gauge if you're flying an airplane
with a liquid cooled engine those
airplanes are not required to have an
oil temperature gauge they have to have
an engine temperature gauge similar to
what you see on the car that you drive
but it's important to keep an eye on
both of these gauges because High
temperatures can cause a decrease in
engine power and a lot of times the
engine could start burning oil and that
could damage the engine and could even
cause catastrophic
failure remember piston driven or
reciprocating engines rely on oil moving
throughout the system to keep the engine
lubricated and cool so if you lose oil
pressure for some reason in either one
of these aircraft it's very likely that
the engine will overheat so if the
pressure isn't reading in the green get
the aircraft on the ground as soon as
possible and Topp her off on oil and
double check for leaks with that in mind
there are a few other things that could
cause the engine to overheat and if
you're oil pressure is in the green but
your engine's still getting kind of
toasty these are some things to try if
you're on the ground one thing that
could cause your engine to overheat is
if you sit in one place too long this
isn't really a problem if you have a
liquid cooled engine but most trainers
are air cooled so if you're sitting
quite a while in one place you only have
the air from the prop to cool the engine
in that case you you might just want to
shut down for a bit if she's getting too
hot on the ground then you can restart
the engine when you're actually ready to
go this isn't really the best option in
flight though I mean I guess technically
it is an option but you're an idiot if
shutting down is the first thing you try
when the engine gets too warm the first
thing you should do is to think about
some of the things that could be causing
your engine to get too hot if you're
running the engine at a high RPM in hot
temperatures or the air is really thin
because of high density altitude these
are some of the conditions that could
cause your engine to get too hot if
you're climbing and this is happening
the best thing to do is pitch down a
little bit and reduce your rate of climb
this will allow your airplane to speed
up a little bit which will allow more
air flow over the engine which will help
cool it off remember your training
aircraft is probably air cooled so if
it's not getting a lot of air flow it's
very likely going to get hot another
thing that could cause your engine to
overheat is if you have the mixture
control set too lean now we're going to
talk about this more in a minute but the
fuel going into the engine actually
helps to cool the engine and by leaning
the mixture this allows us to get better
power when the air is thin but this also
makes the engine hotter so if your
engine's getting hot and your oil
pressure is in the green the first thing
you should always check is the mixture
and if you've leaned it out there's a
good chance it's too lean Rich up the
mixture and see if that fixes the
problem the last option is to reduce the
power this is not really the best option
because fuel does help cool the engine
but reducing the power does also reduce
the RPMs in a fixed pitch propeller so
that is something to consider before we
move on let's take a look at a couple
problems that are often caused by an
engine that is running too hot
detonation and pre-ignition contrary to
what you might think gas does not
explode in the cylinder to push the
Piston down and cause the engine to turn
it burns quickly and smoothly and that
creates the pressure to turn the engine
if it does explode that is what we call
detonation and if that happens it can
damage the the walls of your cylinder
the top of the piston and all kinds of
stuff now as I just mentioned detonation
occurs when the engine is too hot when
the whole cylinder is too warm it's way
more likely for the fuel to explode
because of that if the engine is acting
up and you suspect detonation lower the
nose and pick up some air speed or
increase that mixture if you can cooling
the engine off should keep that from
happening but to keep from damaging the
engine it's also a good idea to pull the
power back a little and reduce the
RPM pre-ignition is another problem that
could occur if your engine's getting too
hot but this usually happens when there
are spots on the cylinder that are red
hot these spots can actually ignite the
fuel before the time is right as you
might imagine this can bend rods and all
kinds of scary stuff but unfortunately
there's not a lot you can do because hot
spots are usually caused by abnormal
wear in those areas once again you could
have an oil leak or maybe a part got
damaged from detonation or something
else
in this situation reducing power might
help you out a little bit but you should
really get that thing on the ground as
soon as possible and get the engine
checked by a mechanic another system you
need to be familiar with is the ignition
system and airplanes have dual ignition
systems one to keep the engine running
and the other one for the wife and kids
not only does having an extra ignition
system make the engine safer and more
reliable but it also improves the
performance as well and that allows the
engine to run way smoother during the
runup you'll be testing each system
separately and when you do that you'll
typically get about 100 more RPM out of
both systems together versus an
individual ignition system now these are
completely different than the one on
your car both ignition systems on your
aircraft have their own Magneto and
those guys are responsible for sending
an electrical charge to the spark plugs
the important thing to remember about
magnetos is that they're turned by the
engine and they have small generators
inside of them that can still send a
spark to the spark plugs if for some
reason the rest of the aircraft was to
to lose electrical power that's good
news for you because if the electrical
system on your aircraft takes a dump on
you or you need to turn it off because
of an electrical fire you should not
lose your engine anyway that's why your
airplane has a master on switch and a
Magneto switch on most aircraft you have
to turn the master on in order to engage
the starter but once the engine is
turning you can turn that Master back
off and the old girl should keep running
keep in mind when we shut down our
engine the way we usually do that is to
pull the mix out and the reason why we
do that is to get rid of all the fuel
out of the cylinder so we don't fou up
the plugs when we're shutting down but
it's also possible to kill the engine by
turning the magnetos off now the
magnetos are kind of special you can't
just turn them off when you turn the mag
switch off you're actually not turning
anything off you're literally grounding
at the mag so they quit sending a spark
over to the engine this is important to
know because if that ground wire gets
disconnected from the mag itself or the
switch inside the cockpit you will will
not be able to shut the engine down by
turning the mag switch to off this might
not seem like a big deal because you can
just pull the mixture out to kill the
engine like you should be doing anyway
the real danger is when you're on the
ground and the engine is not running if
that ground wire is broken or
disconnected and you or someone else
turns the propeller enough the mags will
send a charge over to the spark plugs
and if there's any fuel in the cylinder
when that happens the engine could kick
over and possibly even start up and take
off on you this is why you should never
turn the prop when you're doing a walk
around it's fine to touch it to check
for Nicks and stuff but do not turn it
and once again this design is a good
thing if you lose all electric in your
airplane because your battery dies or
your alternator quits working you're
going to lose all kinds of stuff a bunch
of your gauges will quit working you'll
lose your avionics your radios
transponder lights and even possibly the
flaps but that engine will keep on going
because those mags will continue to fire
because because they're being turned by
the engine and remember if your plane
has analog instruments you still have
most of those at your disposal as well
now there is one more advantage to this
design if you get stuck somewhere with a
dead battery it is possible to still
hand propop a lot of these newer planes
like they did in the old days if you
decide to do this just be careful and
make sure you have a competent pilot at
the controls and not a passenger make
sure they're holding the brakes nice and
firm and use good Communications to make
sure someone doesn't get chopped up by
the propeller but the mags aren't the
only things that are operated by the
engine a lot of aircraft also have an
engine driven fuel pump for the same
reason once again if you were to lose
electric for some reason an engine
driven fuel pump ensures that you can
make it safely to the nearest airfield
and these are usually very reliable
pieces of equipment but we also have a
backup for those as well some aircraft
especially low-wing aircraft have extra
fuel pumps that are operated
electrically and these can be used if
the engine driven fuel pump fails
and they're also often used to help
start the engine easier if your airplane
has an auxiliary pump like this the P
usually recommends using it for takeoff
Landing or maneuvering close to the
ground and that keeps you from losing
your engine too close to the ground if
the primary pump fails during that time
but you don't want to use these things
the whole time you're flying they're not
meant for that and they won't last very
long if you operate them that way with
that in mind high-wing aircraft like
cess 172s or Piper Cubs don't usually
have auxilary fuel pumps like this if
the engine pump fails those aircraft are
designed to feed by gravity instead
don't you just love all these little
design features that keep you from dying
I know I do next let's talk a little bit
more about the propeller and some of the
things you should know about that little
guy the propeller is basically a
miniature Wing that spins around and
creates lift that pushes the airplane
forward this is what we call thrust
thrusts like ducks and geese when they
take off what they have thrust just like
the wing the angle of of attack on the
propeller plays a huge role in how much
thrust it produces and if you want the
best performance all the time you really
need a propeller that you can change the
pitch or the blade angle but that makes
learning how to fly even harder so we
have what you call fixed pitch
propellers in most training aircraft and
the angle on these are set so that you
get pretty decent performance during
climb out without giving up too much
performance during cruise I guess you
could say that they're usually set at
the best average and you can actually
buy props that perform a little bit
better on climb or cruise but if you
want the absolute best performance you
need a variable pitch propeller now I'm
going to go into a lot more detail on
variable pitch propellers in a future
video but let's talk briefly about these
guys for just a minute because you can
actually fly one of these once you get
your private Palace license keep in mind
there are a couple different types of
variable pitch propellers but the one
you're most likely to encounter is the
constant speed propeller most of you
guys have probably already seen
airplanes with these propellers in the
cockpit these typically have the same
red mixture knob and the black throttle
control that you're used to seeing but
they also have a Blue Knob that controls
the speed of the propeller and the way
this system controls the speed of the
propeller is kind of interesting when
the pilot selects a speed that he wants
the engine and propeller to turn the
governor changes the pitch of the
propeller to maintain that speed for
example if I select 2,400 RPM with my
propeller knob if the engine is making
too much power the governor will
increase the blade angle to slow the
engine down and keep it from turning too
fast if my engine is producing very
little power the governor will turn the
blaze to a position where they're not
creating much resistance and this keeps
the engine and propeller RPM at a
constant speed that must be why we call
these constant speed propellers what a
great name on these aircraft when you
move the throttle you're basically
creating more or less power in the
engine and the prop moves to keep the
RPM constant but the thrust you get is
different depending on the speed of your
engine and the power you have selected
high power settings on the engine are
measured by a manifold pressure gauge
like this in fact if you have a constant
speed prop this manifold pressure gauge
is a required instrument per
91205 anyway high RPM settings and high
manifold pressure yield more thrust
while low RPM settings with low manifold
pressure yields very little once again I
don't want to go into too much detail
today but if you learn to fly one of
these guys there's something you really
need to know anytime you operate the
propeller and throttle there's a very
specific order that you want to do that
if you're increasing power you always
want to increase the propeller RPM first
and then increase the manifold pressure
if you're decreasing the power you want
to decrease the manifold pressure first
and then reduce the RPM the reason for
this is because if you run the engine at
a high manifold pressure and a low RPM
setting you can very easily overstress
and damage the engine and you know as
well as I do that the engine is not
something you want to lose in Flight
okay we've already talked a little bit
about that red mixture knob in the
cockpit but let's go into a little bit
more detail on that system in order to
get the absolute best power out of an
engine the fuel and air mixture going
into the engine have to be the perfect
ratio well as you might remember the air
gets thinner at higher altitudes so if
we want to get the best power we need to
adjust the fuel air mixture when we're
at higher altitudes now I've said this
in the past but your airplane does not
care about true altitude and there are
actually a few things that can make the
air thinner in in addition to your
actual altitude remember the 4 H's high
pressure altitude hot temperatures and
humid conditions can reduce the amount
of air that's going into your engine
because of that we need to lean the
mixture when we're at a high density
altitude that's one of the reasons why
we like to calculate density altitude
before flight that lets you know if you
should be leaning on the ground or at
what altitude you should start leaning
the mixture now if you read the PO in
most training aircraft most of them will
tell you not to lean the mixture below
3,000 ft I've seen some of them say not
to lean the mixture below 5,000 ft but
if you're going to be flying at a
density altitude above these numbers
full Rich does not equal best power I'm
your density in order to get the
absolute best power for highdensity
altitudes all we have to do is adjust
this little red knob now do not ever
just pull the knob straight back during
flight that would completely cut off
fuel to your engine that's why they put
this little safety button on here to
keep you from accidentally being stupid
anyway as you twist this knob
counterclockwise this moves the mixture
back very slowly and this reduces the
amount of fuel going into the engine
this allows us to Target the best ratio
of fuel and air now be sure to consult
your pH for details on how to lean the
mixture in your exact airplane but
typically if you don't have an EGT gauge
the procedure is to reduce the fuel
until the engine starts to run a little
bit rough and then increase the fuel
flow slightly I like to do 3/4 turns
anyway if your engine is running too
rich it's going to seem like it's
running really rough if you're
experiencing engine roughness leaning
the mixture is probably the best thing
to try first if you run the engine too
rich too long this can also file the
plugs so leaning the mixture might not
always fix the problem right away in
fact if you're taking off from a high
elevation airport and you're noticing
that she's running a little bit rough
but it's still passing the mag check
there's a good chance that this is your
problem it's not uncommon to need a lean
the mixture on the ground in high
elevation areas like Colorado or Montana
with all that in mind you can also run
the engine too lean now if you go super
lean the engine will just quit running
altogether but before that happens the
engine will actually run too good and
what I mean by that is that your engine
can get super hot remember what we
talked about earlier hot engines are bad
you can get some serious engine damage
if you're running too hot once again
check the p and see what your
manufacturer recommends so you do it
correctly with all that in mind on the
desent when you're coming in for a
landing most PHS recommend setting the
mixture to full Rich this is because
you'll be operating at low power
settings or even at idle during The
Descent so there won't be a ton of fuel
going into the engine anyway but in
addition to that as you descend the air
gets thicker if you don't rich in the
mixture enough the engine could get way
too lean during The Descent and then KY
just kidding but the engine could get
too hot if you forget to do this this is
actually one reason why some Pilots
believe that shock cooling is a myth
that might be something worth discussing
in a future video now discussion on the
fuel system just wouldn't be complete if
I didn't talk a little bit about the
carburetor and what we call induction
icing before you can understand
carburetor icing you really need to have
a basic understanding of how the
carburetor Works keep in mind there are
a few different types of carburetors and
a lot of newer aircraft fuel systems are
now fuel injected but many training
aircrafts still make use of a float type
carburetor to get fuel into the
cylinders and the way it does that is
actually kind of interesting the most
important part of the carburetor is the
intake this is where air is brought in
from suction from the
engine and as the air goes through the
carb it passes through a narrow
passageway which causes a Venturi effect
as you may remember when air is forced
through narrow areas this causes that
air to speed up and that reduces the air
pressure in that area when that pressure
drops it actually sucks fuel out of this
float area over here because the
pressure in the float area is higher so
I guess you could say that this system
really
sucks anyway that causes the high-
pressure fuel to spray a fine Mist into
the cylinders and that makes it burn
nice and even to create the most power
possible now carburetors work really
well but they're also very susceptible
to icing and that simply means ice build
up inside the carb and the reason for
this is because of that vent effect that
we talked about earlier when air is
forced through that narrow area that air
speeds up once again we want that
because that causes suction which causes
our fuel to spray in a nice Misty
fashion but it also causes the
temperature of that air to drop as well
and that temperature drop can be as much
as 50° F remember the air in our
atmosphere actually has water vapor in
it along with nitrogen oxygen and and a
bunch of other gases this means that
when that air comes into the carb the
moisture in it can freeze and cause ice
build up inside the carburetor keep in
mind carb icing can occur in a lot of
different weather conditions but you're
most likely to experience carburetor
icing when you're at a low power setting
and the temperature is between 20 and
70° F and when there's a lot of humidity
in the air remember these numbers
there's a good chance that these could
show up again on your written exam or
your check ride right now I can see you
have a confused look on your face you
might be wondering how you're less
likely to get carbing if the temperature
is below 20° F think back on our lessons
about the weather remember warmer air is
capable of holding a lot more moisture
in fact for every 20° F increase the air
can actually hold twice as much moisture
so at temperatures below 20° there's
just not as much moisture in the air to
freeze and build up inside the
carburetor now when I does build up it
tends to build up in the throat of the
carburetor and sometimes on the throttle
valve and that's because that's where
the temperature of the air drops and
causes that moisture to freeze because
of that when ice starts to build up here
the first indication of induction icing
is almost always a drop in RPM think
about it logically if this throat is
getting shrunk down by the ice the
engine is going to have the same
reaction as if you're closing off the
valve and keeping some of the air from
coming in so let's say you suspect
carbing because you experienced a loss
of RPM or maybe your engine isn't making
the power you think it should be if
you're at a low power setting you
probably want to turn the carb heat on
when you do that your engine is not
going to start running better right away
in fact when you first turn on the
carpat you should always expect to drop
an RPM and the reason for that is
because carb heat decreases engine
performance if you've already started
your flight training you probably
already noticed this when you test the
carb heat on the run up this happens
because the carb heat directs hot air
from the engine or the engine exhaust
depending on the design into the
carburetor to melt that ice remember hot
air is thinner that means that your
engine gets less air when you operate
with the carb heat so essentially you're
running your fuel air mixture Super Rich
that's why we don't use carb heat all
the time it takes away some of your
performance I scared myself pretty good
one time on a takeoff because I
accidentally left the carb heat on
during the takeoff and the climb out
that's definitely something you do not
want to do especially when you need all
the power you can get and that's the
nice thing about these new fuel injected
systems you don't have to deal with carb
heat and you don't have to worry about
carb icing but you're also going to pay
quite a bit more if you want to purchase
one of those guys fuel injected systems
are for rich people even if you perform
a perfect pre-flight inspection there's
always a chance that something could go
wrong with your aircraft I'm going to go
into a lot more detail on this when I
talk about engine out
scenarios but I do want to leave you
with a couple things to think about
since you could get asked about this on
your written exam the most important
thing in every emergency is maintaining
control of the aircraft in fact the Air
Force actually teaches this as the first
step in every emergency after you get
the aircraft under control then you can
analyze the situation take the proper
action and land as soon as conditions
permit but sometimes you won't always be
able to perform the rest of these steps
what if you take off and you lose your
engine the second your airborn in a
situation like this it's very likely
that you won't have time to do any of
these other things but you can still
maintain control of the aircraft maybe I
didn't check for water in the fuel like
I should have on the pre-flight
inspection and now my engine cut out
troubleshooting 3 ft above the runway is
not what I want to do instead
immediately establish Best Glide and
then capture a good Landing attitude and
focus on getting the airplane back onto
the runway if you lose your engine on
the takeoff roll like this just land
straight ahead on the runway even if you
do have a Tailwind yeah you're probably
going to float a little bit because you
have a faster ground speed but there's
not much you can do about it if you lose
your engine and you're out of usable
Runway plan on Landing the aircraft
Straight Ahead do not turn around unless
you're 100% sure you can make it back
many people have died because they
misjudged their ability to make it back
I'd like to discuss this more in a
future video but until you know for sure
plan on Landing Straight Ahead even if
it is in the trees or something once
again in this situation it's extremely
important to capture Best Glide this
does two things first it allows you to
Glide as far as possible before you
touch down second if you maintain a
constant air speed this will allow you
to judge exactly where you're going to
touch down which will help you put the
airplane down into a more favorable
landing spot if you let your air speed
move up and down it's going to be
impossible to accurately determine where
you'll touch down and at that point you
might as well just close your eyes and
hope for the best don't really do that
once again we're going to be talking
more about emergencies in a future
episode but this is enough to get you
through the written exam and get you
thinking about the things you should be
thinking about when you start your
flight training I hope you enjoyed this
video if you did please smash that like
button for me I've got two videos left
in this series and my Private Pilot
ground course is complete when that next
video is done I'll throw it right here
thanks for watching guys
[Music]
see
he